okay so I want to have a discussion here
and I want to talk about the first
episode of the watchman TV series you
know Watchmen episode 1 I want do a
review on this because you know normally
I kind of stick to comics but I think
this is cool right because the Watchmen
is one of those series that is so unique
in terms of how it functions Ronnie the
Watchmen show his honor the Watchmen
comic has spawned like entire thesis
right like people have have written
thesis for like filling out philosophy
classes that things like that you know
entire courses have been taught about
like the philosophy of the Watchmen by
Alan Moore and so to turn it into a TV
series is is a really good thing and it
can be kind of a dangerous game for
super diehard Watchmen fans but uh but I
think it I think it's pretty solid like
I think it's really really awesome the
reality is that I didn't really know
what to expect
going into it I did to a degree just
because of the fact that I read enough
to know the Watchmen TV series takes
place after the original events but I
didn't read a whole lot into it I didn't
read a lot of the articles because I
didn't really want to have anything
spoiled for me I wanted to go ahead and
just sort of go in blind for the most
part and just kind of figure things out
for myself um I like the way things are
going like I like the way the show of
the show progresses I mean you know
spoilers a few spoilers here and there
for those of you guys who are who
haven't seen it yet there's a few things
that sort of caught me off guard right
the idea that the police are using masks
that kind of threw me off right because
masks were outlawed by vigilantes or
outlawed for basically anybody to use
right like you couldn't use a mask and
be a superhero um the notion that that
kind of has has sort of been turned on
its head and police use them as a means
to hide their identities from vigilantes
or those who would try to take out
police officers are some of the cavalry
different things like that it's sort of
a cool concept um it's very real and
very tangible right like I me imagine
for example the American people are just
like we're tired of police brutality
like you know we're gonna treat police
the way they treat the way they treat
people and then suddenly cops start
covering their faces things like that so
you don't really know who they are it's
it's it's it seems very real like
something that could actually happen in
the real world and like the next 10
years or something like that so that
that thing that that aspect I really
really enjoyed
the notion of seventh cavalry strikes me
a little strange right and I understand
where they're coming from insofar as the
perversion of the the perversion of a
symbol there was originally designed
stand for one thing and is now standing
for something else I never really saw
Rorschach as an individual who was like
let's take out cops or anything like
that you know some kind of extreme
terrorist or something along those lines
I always saw Rorschach as a guy who was
just sort of like everybody like anybody
who is corrupt is going to be dealt with
accordingly right you know cop political
official otherwise like you know a very
Punisher Eskin character writing you
know and so for I was like taking the
law into his own hands and just kind of
be like sometimes the law is not enough
you know sometimes people need to be
dealt with accordingly and just kind of
going from there
um it's I never really saw him as an
agent of like chaos you know or an agent
of a guy who would you know who would go
around and say like we're gonna take out
cops now in reality I don't think the
7th Calvary has been fully fleshed out
but if I'm being honest I think we've
kind of seen them pretty much all work
although we really need and so far as
like what their motivations and what
they're ayat what their ideologies are
but again there's a lot more of his oats
to go so there's probably a lot more
fleshing out that's gonna happen there
but I think it's sort of strange and a
little interesting to see the Rorschach
concept used in that way I would see the
were shot concept being used more for
like like the Joker film for example
people who were just who don't really
take the long to their own hands so much
as they promote lawlessness you know
like vigilantes and then just say oh I
guess the devices do take the law into
their own hands and then just saying
like we were worried wearing a workshop
mask because now you know and just kind
of going forward and you know going
forward from there so I don't know what
individuals who promote civil unrest I
could see you know usually were shy
masks but ya know it's it's it's
interesting there because when when I
look at it there were a few things that
sort of stood out to me right like one
my first question going into the show is
is it going to take place after the
events of the movie or after the events
of the comic that was that was really
the biggest question that I had here and
of course you know it takes place after
the comic book and and looking at that
at first I wasn't really sure but as I
began to go through I was like okay so
there's no real references to like the
explosions across the world that happen
from Adrian Veidt right like
you know him blowing up all these other
places instead like weather when they
have that one guy in the pod and things
like that and they show that newspaper
clip and so on and it's like do you
believe that interdimensional invasions
are a real possibility you know that
kind of thing
and it's like okay so they're making a
reference to the interdimensional alien
that was used or a monster that was used
at the end of of the Watchmen comic that
was used by Ozymandias you know that
that attacked New York and killed a
whole bunch of people so okay cool like
I could roll with that um the the
reference to dr. Manhattan just being
there you know or at least kind of being
on Mars or her out doing his own thing
or what have you I think it's kind of
cool I think it's a pretty smart move to
sort of leave him out of it I know that
in the in the in the preview at the end
of the first episode there was one scene
where a guy has a looks like he has a
blue finger and halves on a table or
something like that if I imagine if dr.
Manhattan appears in The Watchmen show I
think really more of a flashback than
anything else I don't think we'll
actually see him doing anything
particular now it may be that there's
spoilers out there to say here's exactly
what's gonna happen with Manhattan I
haven't looked into spoilers too much I
kind of want to save that as a surprise
for myself but uh but ya know it's it's
it's cool here's a funny here's a
question that I have here right because
there's one point where you see a
newspaper where you have that that one
guy who Lou who's played by a Louis
Gossett jr. the the guy who's the older
version a little kid that you saw at the
very beginning and any he hasn't there's
a newspaper that he's holding that you
only see like a portion of it this is
like Adrian Veidt officially declared
dead or something like that
at least that's what it looked like to
me and and of course you're not finding
out Jeremy Irons is basically Adrian
Veidt but you know he invited still very
much alive that intrigued me because as
soon as I thought about that I was like
so is this kind of like bookend in the
Doomsday Clock is that what this is
gonna do like it's gonna explain the the
you know what happened between the
events of the original Watchmen and the
Doomsday Clock comic or is it just kind
of out there by itself it has nothing to
do with what's going on with Doomsday
Clock I don't know the answer to that
question if it did have anything to tie
in the Doomsday Clock he would do it
loosely insofar as that wouldn't involve
any of the characters from DC they would
just involve you know the the
like Watchmen themselves and it may end
with Adrian Veidt being like it now
we're gonna go to a different universe
and try to find Manhattan there's
something like that you know but uh but
nonetheless you know it's it's the the
show itself it's good here's one of the
big things that kind of struck me as
strange whenever you go at least in my
experience anyway or whenever I see the
first episode of a show the first
episode really seems to serve the
purpose of not really being like a like
an hour long or a half-hour long have
along that the episodes are it's not
really designed to be that long of like
a preview like you know in this season
of whatever this show is here's an
hour-long preview of what's to come but
certainly hit on on more than a few
months and to em in terms of creating
the tone of the show in terms of what
we're gonna see as far as like how the
characters function and and what would
what the overall tone in terms of
violence and things like that's gonna be
I think it did a great job but looking
at the previews for the second episode
there's a lot that we haven't seen yet
now I think that's good
in so far is that leaves stuff to the
imagination and it leaves us to kind of
wonder what direction the show is gonna
go in and how far down this rabbit hole
we're really gonna go but at the same
time it's kind of like okay but like the
first episode feels so different from
what the previews look like for that for
the second second episode even the
future episodes now again that's the
nature of the beast right I mean you
know it's designed to be one of these
things where like as the show progresses
the show of walls and crows and it
becomes totally different from what it
was I mean after all you know if if the
entire if the entire series of Breaking
Bad felt like episode 1 it would have
burned out super fast would have burned
out like that right people would have
been like okay this is dumb and they
would have turned it off so it makes
sense that it would evolve and it would
grow into change feel so that that kind
of thing so I don't really hold that
it's like a strike against the show or
anything just caught me a cover sort of
interesting Regina King is amazing but
she's awesome in that show I love the
way she plays her character Don Johnson
I feel like she lasted longer I feel
like getting rid of him at the end of
the first episode kind of sucks because
and the reason why is I think they're
using the death of his character as a
means to sort of explain why it is that
like Regina Keens gonna go on this kind
of Mort hath but I feel like she already
had that explanation right I mean like
you literally get the story of her
character where she's standing in front
of all those kids and she's like well
you know I was a cop him before cops are
able to hide their faces people knew who
we were
track me down they shot me and you know
so on and so forth and so she already
has a vendetta against so 7th cavalry
guys you know I guess maybe this kind of
adds on to it but it feels kind of
unnecessary and I loved Don Johnson's
character you know I'd love the wit you
know his character but Jud I loved him
in terms of how he be lady because
initially I was always like well maybe
he's like a mole maybe he's part of the
seventh Cavalry but like on the inside
and he's like feeding him information
stuff like that I guess kind of snuffing
that out and nipping in the bud really
sort of takes care of that um I don't
know maybe it's possible that he's not
even dead at all yeah here's something I
don't know why you wouldn't be but you
know still it's it's it's it's
interesting it's just kind of a strange
strange choice you know kind of a kind
of weird choice but again I realized
that this one I'll kind of nitpicking
you know kind of looking at small little
things and picking them but um in terms
of my perspective and the overall tone
of the show I loved it look I thought
the Watchmen show was was incredibly
good um the character of Lori okay see
here's one of the big things after the
Watchmen comics were over and you and
you finished it you never really found
out what happened to like night owl'
into you know laurie juspeczyk and those
Karadzic at least with Doomsday Clock
that you have you never found out what
happened and then and it wasn't until
later on in Doomsday Clock that you end
up realizing like they settled down and
basically adopted you know how to kid
that kind of a thing or at least they
would have a kid anyway um from dr.
Manhattan's vision that they would have
adopted the the daughter of marionette
and and they would have gone forward
from there but presumably their entire
lives were wiped out you know when the
earth ended basically in a nuclear
holocaust um but I was basically yet in
this what you end up finding out at
least from from what we've seen is that
instead of it being laurie juspeczyk
she's called Laurie Blake and I like
that idea because what it means is that
Lori is full-on accepted the fact like
the comedians are dad or at least that
seems to be the case which I did I
actually sort of dig that um I think
that's that's a pretty good nod to the
to the old comics um and then in turn
she kind of goes forward accordingly my
question is is she still in a
relationship with mine oh well I guess
she is she is still part of you know
part of his life and you know they do in
their own thing or you know how all that
went for speaking tonight now it was
cool to see the ship I dug that just to
see is to see a ship and see them shoot
down that plane that was pretty awesome
to see those little remnants sort of
gathered together
um I don't really know how all that ties
together if 9l willingly handed it over
or if it was all co-opted if it was all
just taken over by the government and it
was like all your stuff you know all
your vase now belong to us you know I
don't know is it all your base are
belong to us I don't know that's that
was you know that was the intention or
anything but um you know it's it's in
terms of the show it feels it obviously
builds on the comics but it feels
different enough that there's enough
interest and intrigue there then I'm
like okay I wonder where this goes and
wonder what's Russian this is gonna go
in I'm curious about that but I don't
know I mean you know it's it's it's one
of these things where as the show
progresses either get turned out to be
super good or could just fall flat on
its face based on what I've seen on the
first episode I think it's gonna turn
out to be exceedingly good I think it's
gonna progress and and become an amazing
show I don't recall if there's only
limited to one season or if they're if
they're gonna do it for a few seasons
that I'm not a hundred percent sure
about um I feel like I want to say that
it's that it's only one season like I
read that somewhere but I'm not gonna
take that as an absolute truth ah but if
you're on the fence about it I would
highly suggest checking it out right
it's it's it's an awesome first episode
getting into it um again I think Jeremy
Irons and I was actually talking to
Mariah about this I feel like Jeremy
Irons would have been a great choice for
Ozymandias in the first movie where like
I feel like he would have been a great
choice she made a really good point in
saying that she thought he was too old
but uh but I was like I feel like you
would have been a great a great
Ozymandias um my question is like what's
the whole idea but about the the plot
and the watchmakers son that's what I
want to know I assume this it's about
Jon Osterman about dr. Manhattan but I'm
not a hundred percent sure either way
like it's it's awesome like the show is
super good it's it's wildly intriguing
I'm definitely going back for episode to
you and you know if episode 2 feels
anything like episode 1 in terms of like
the action and the sequences and all
that kind of stuff is definitely gonna
hold my attention I loved it I
absolutely loved it and I'll definitely
be back for more so uh yeah with that
being said guys let me know what you
guys think about about this review you
know what you think about reviewing
episodes of The Watchmen without me so
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you guys are new here too comments
explained to make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]